But so what what makes it so are you with your eyes what you are doing with your T.V. The idea is to be open.
I think open for. Looking for interesting solutions in nature and.
The approach probably quite unique still for my group but I think in becoming more
and more popular is if we have two directions of how we'll look at nature. One is.
Let's say there is an interesting creature doing something in icing and we're trying to learn the.
What is happening and maybe apply it. That's one approach and apply it.
Maybe to different things but even more interesting is just emerging now is that instead of.
Looking for one creature that tells us something. What if we take lessons from completely different organisms.
They have nothing in common. They have different environments but one can teach something.
But it's not enough for certain purposes. Together with yet another.
Organism you can learn something else
and combining lessons from completely different organisms that have all their things for. For their specific needs.
But then to solve a certain problem so that's a really interesting approach is to really take small lessons from
different from plants from little stars from because that I have research where combining lessons from this creature
with this. So they have nothing in common but that one taught us something.
This one taught us something combining them together to produce a new technology that would never appear if we wouldn't
come by Miss. Lessons. So that the idea of combining different creatures to go. Some will was born from.
So can you explain what. So you probably know what. Who are starfish.
And I see your shit and so this is the closes role of relative for both.
So it's also you see has five fold symmetry of the body just like a starfish.
But it's called brittle stuff that its arms are called brittle as it's very fast.
You see it's black and it's already dead. Of course but during the day it is black and during the night. It is white.
And the way changes color is. By introducing inside the heat skeleton.
Black people and that covers the lens just like some glasses that change color when there's too much light.
This is what this organism does and makes light reception dynamic depending how much light outside.
So that's the lesson from here. This one has structural color. So it's this blue.
Is structural color structural color means that it's not chemical color.
It's not coming from pigment it's coming from and arrangement of features.
It's coming purely from distances between features in this structure so the penny how close they are it would be the
blue green. So it has almost nothing to do with the material.
I can get blue color in any material but just making it in the regular arranged. Now this color is not dynamic.
It's not changing in any way. So we combine the idea of how liquid here changes color of this organism.
And introduce this quid. As an active element.
Into structures that would make very similar to that butterfly a result of that is that we put together a new
technology where the color can change as in a function of infiltration of A with lid.
But then we use this for very interesting applications. We're looking how that concept was liquid that.
Suddenly changes color in different ways and I will probably show you a couple of those things in the lab.
We use thought as sensor. We can use it to. For encryption.
Because there are certain messages can be written there
and you will never see them with actual have a butterfly with the two.
The two is coming out only when you are exposed to a liquid.
And that gives us a way to have missed messages longer that would appear only when you expose it to right with with.
So the overall idea of dynamic materials.
As I can but in this particular case by combining these strategies
but we have many more examples of one organism tissues something and the other one.
She teaches so that more and together it's interesting. And you lied to us.
So we're making now and we're actually making. I actually have a lot of but most of them are.
Design School because I use them for teaching but we'll see some of them in my lab where it will.
You will see it looks exactly like this beautiful blue color but it's actually material that will make.
But compared to a very it's as simple as imagine a shot glass that has beautiful color
and depending on what you drink it would give you different messages that you don't know really exist it's a simple way
to make it beautiful.
But in fact we can use it in particular we're working with the Department of Transportation to design it into a sensor
for detection of oil. Quality. So in North Dakota.
They're pulling out a lot of oil there is no five line and they're transporting it by rail.
And within the last couple of years there were a lot of explosions because oil was not properly labeled by what type of
oil that is. So to have a very simple detector that has beautiful color. And.
Depending on the quality of well this well would either infiltrated or not
and therefore the color will change in certain ways. Has a very simple.
You don't need to use fancy equipment it's almost a pregnancy test or Ph paper.
You've put it in oil and you know what quality it is in which. Container.
You need to pack it so three or four major form from all your plans or.
You learn from the characteristics from your work there you go deeper into what about is nobody. That's right.
So I don't call it by a mimicry. Because I'm not mimicking nature. It is by inspired science.
So I use it as an inspiration and things that I make a modern ceral in the used the same way nature use it.
Often for completely different application it just so new design principles that nature has evolved become very
interesting approaches that one can use for smart materials design. So it is not mimicking nature.
It's taking lessons being is inspired by nature and think where we can use these. Beyond well beyond of what.
Nature is doing and also how we can fit this moment mimic the entire complexity of natural system
and probably I don't want to. So the bother flying this.
See Us humans and I need to multiply the need to do all kinds of things.
If I'm making a device let's say to detect quality of oil.
I don't need all these features so being able to abstract from nature. So to take these principles and.
Simplify them sometimes or reformulate them in such a way that it can be used somewhere else.
This is what we actually do. Best where all organisms. I am in not agree with that I'm not sure. That evolution.
Always Meigs the best choice in the sense that there is always local pressures local environmental conditions.
And often. Nature has the materials. Stuck with certain choices that is very expensive.
To change and then within that range. I would say that. My Would you call solutions are often subtheme or not optimal.
We have our ideas why in particular publish. And number of papers.
So if we look at this paper which section describing how this organism changes color and but it's a skeleton.
So nature often does something we do not do yet which is designing one material for multiple purposes.
So often nature will design my not be best for each of the purposes it has to serve.
That it does it very well for multiple things for example if I design lances and these alliances on top of a skeleton.
Maybe I'll design lenses in a different way and better than these in a different material
but the sane material is supposed to be a skeleton. So it's not just optical a perfect.
It has to be structurally perfect. So neither of them are probably perfect.
But to think about one material that can do both things well enough. Then evolution finds the best solution for that.
And sometimes will can these optimisation you there are so many parameters you need to optimize for.
Maybe there are some that we don't even know about and then what we can say flaws of evolution of it.
It's not perfect it could be done better.
Maybe not because the material is supposed to do many other things for example multiply. Dissolve at certain moment.
And when our regular approaches of why not to make it out of Wes why not make it out of metal will not be political.
And therefore not used in nature. So multi functionality is a need very interesting approach.
It's also what you want doing. Yes major world. I don't know what I would say that I would just say that.
Maybe there are creatures that already have these features but what we are trying to do is to combine.
Unrelated lessons from different organisms together to solve an interesting societal problem.
It's interesting technical problem to create a new material that can do something that our current materials can't do
so. It is not the next nature but I would say its next generation of events materials materials that.
Respond to environment so why can't we have our buildings. That. Either bring us. War shut.
The They're wet ability depending on whether it's the rain outside of not my Can't we have our entire Windows that
would.
In a smart way which means in response to temperature outside to light outside change the performance even to have the
lights through not there is so many things that one can do if we consider general lessons from nature that we haven't
yet. Understood. Dude very well. Which is. Risk.
PONSON us which is adaptive nature
and ability to reconfigure just if we would have materials of that kind that would be a really interesting one for
forty Knology What's the most productive. Plant material. That's a tough question.
I have a very big group and in a way each of these projects is my baby.
So you don't ask which baby you like most out of your kids. Each of them in some ways.
Why is different parts of what is important to me if you would ask. What is the most interesting science.
It's one part of that I don't often in this case ask question is it going to be useful is just to uncover interesting.
Mechanisms ideas and what nature does in interesting ways
and there are a couple of things where I'm very proud in this direction.
For example to understand the structure of this punch. So. To.
To understand that the organism was able to create the fiber optical network
and the beautiful skeleton everything out of glass and you explain how this is structurally
and from materials point of view its design and its architecture. That's so I'm proud of.
I also like in this direction ability to grow pretty much any crystal.
I want with me to look at some of them in the microscope later on. Just to grow flowers.
That are just size of human hair are smaller than that but in any shape
or form so that to understand the underlying science so well that we can do it so I'm very proud of that part.
Now the other side though our study is that we do not just science purpose.
But coming not from science and then thinking well one can use but to do it the other way around.
Starting with the problem. And then think how one can solve it. So these are more technology or application.
Oriented studies and there.
And the ones that I'm most proud of probably are the two developments that have happened in my group when I was asked.
Five six years and these are. Two technologies one is based on inspiration coming from Picher plant.
Where we really developed a completely new family of materials that can be designed in a very simple way this moment we
can make it in metal in Poland mined glass in any material but the material that would repel.
What you want to repel it will repel ice it with repel barnacles and mussels to repel blood.
To help Syria and to create the family off and they found willing to or else parrot proud of this work
and I'm very proud of work.
Where we can you use self assembled materials for the structural color actually as senses as a way to detect. And.
Three feel.
How much rolls are exposed to environment so these are two that are related to applications so they are the overall
idea for that came from. We want to solve the problem of let's say falling.
What should we do which organism should we look at to help us do it.
So not from the organisms to obligation but rather from application.
To now to organisms and the chills system that can help. And when you look at it. We can create or.
There is there is an endless future of possibilities. Your your science.
For a whole new world opening your biology in this way. Thinking about Europe versus other materials.
I agree the I hope that there would be more
and more studies of this kind you just said a good example of that is our recent paper actually published this year in
nature. Was on making the most efficient.
Heat exchangers the most efficient water collection systems
and the way we designed it was by combining lessons from three different natural systems where we were looking on how
to optimize so we parameters. All of them are orthogonal to each other very different.
And combining these three organisms gave us the best solution. Nothing in technology works as well as that.
So the combined lessons from Desert be taught. From cactus and. From the chip plant.
And we're able to put together something interesting but neither of them alone will teach us.
Now how many of these capabilities. I'm sure it's endless.
There are so many organisms and there are so many things about organisms that nobody has started yet
and anglers convene a nation of something that nature evolved here because it was important for this organism
and somewhere else because it was important for another organism and together.
It gives I'm usually unexpected solution that nobody can easily come up with that concept so it's not general obvious.
We're not trying to go and. And to try to do the obvious science it's it's.
I'm leavin untraditional unorthodox combinations that we're trying to do where you start from.
Where review your passion for. Looking at major words. I can't even remember I think it was always that.
I guess in some ways there was a little bit of a unpleasant beginning of all that.
When I was a child when I was two years old when I first time when I went to kindergarten and. My.
Nurse in the kindergarten by mistake gave me triple those of ten of that scene. Four and three Paula.
That scene at that time Vixen was. The wife and I actually was paralyzed for. A number of years.
So when I was paralyzed I was in the sanatorium. Out on the Black Sea. I was exposed to.
Two shells two waves two to Black Sea at that time there at.
Unpleasant times but at the same time it was the time when there are kids up running around and playing
and I was in a chair. And. That was the beginning of looking observing nature and loving it. Really. Then in school.
I guess. So I was one of all the mathematical volunteers.
So science was always something I wanted to do it was never a question. It was a question of which science. But.
I guess that. I. And my parents were very influential for me.
We constantly had discussions and some fights between them whether I would follow my dad steps on my mom steps
and I decided to combine both my my mom was a medical doctor. And civically interested in infectious diseases.
And I do now. A lot of work in.
Making materials for medical devices that prevent infections that prevent the cheeriest to form.
And my dad is a structural engineer.
Who's wanted me to be an engineer and this combination actually is really interesting.
I guess that they mentioned I can track it back to the time
when I was three four years old this year where was your if you were. You know and that's right. And I'm sorry. What.
Always interested me. And it's something that probably.
I keep doing it till now is pattern from ation it's not only seashells let's say.
But we know how waves leave interesting signs on ascent.
So these bromide and the patterns left behind by by the waves on. On ascent was my obsession for a very long time.
So since I was mostly interested in mathematics at them as a student did in school.
I actually thought that I would be applied mathematics and but them. I was convinced that by doing physical chemistry.
I could still do a lot of mathematics but I can also do physics chemistry and biology.
And it was quite a come convincing argument to to. To get the job in Moscow University the chemistry department.
So it's better information.
How different features form and many things in my research in particular better than zero in these phony Christophe's
or patterns. On this bondage. You see probably butt. The patterns on these sponsors are extremely close so.
If you look at the heart this is a not living anymore but it's a natural spine which it's fully This is skeleton of it.
It's fully made of glass just like we make our buildings and our windows
but I hope you see that in addition to just beautiful glass architecture.
Here is there a regular It has something like a chessboard structure.
So there's one window open another one is closed and that's again pattern.
I was interested
when I started to look at that how this symmetry that can arise from a living organism how can it foam a skeleton with
such an incredible regularity. If you look here. There are also diagonal elements running through this point.
And they're running. Exactly. Every force square every four square. Every second square. It has a dark square.
So there's an incredible regularity so the origin of these features the origin of this order is all within the.
Our studies of how patterns. How interesting assembly works. What the human.
What do you do with the information you got from the spot which you why with what we do here you. So this is.
There is a couple of things that we are trying to do hopefully is to what we do is we simplify this. Spawn's design.
So these are three D. Printed.
And this one has all the structural elements this one chair has this one has all that Wes this one.
So we make different types of this.
Structure to understand why nature ended up with this specific architecture to make the most.
Mechanical with strong material. So the. The lessons that we learn from the art is how to make. Most.
Mechanical or strong glass that one can range from very small scale to their lifestyle. So within this point in fact I.
Gave couple of lectures. Describing. But if you look at this from every level. I can probably teach an entire class of.
Civil engineering and everything we use in the design. Laminated materials. Or fiber inforced materials or.
Cemented structures. Everything every element that we use now is actual ready used by the spine.
So it's a lot of interesting things where there is additional features in particular hierarchy how nature makes it from
the nano scale up to this macroscopic scale. To avoid cards that this point has in the sea.
So there is a lot of interesting lessons but again there is a lesson in multi functionality. This is a skeleton.
But it's also. In our opinion designed. To control and optimize three functions at least.
Which is it has to be strong because it's skeleton. But it also has five. But these are optical fibers and that couple.
Into this structure most of them. I already removed for my research.
So the structure has to act as a beacon in the scene.
So how one can use go as to make optical fibers
and also skeletons out of glass in the actual conditions not the two thousand degrees C. As we deal with glass.
But in addition to that spine is a primitive organism sponges bre. And. He lived by.
Pumping seawater through these openings all these openings in its structure is for pumping seawater.
Then organic particles that are coming through this body. Are up taken.
And the psych toast by this primitive it's not a woman it's a multicellular organism.
But it doesn't have organs it has nothing is really primitive. How ever.
It's able on combining optical properties mechanical properties and what we believe the design with this nice.
Structure of opening one poor closing another one has having served function to optimize fluidics so that it doesn't
need to use too much energy to pump.
Water through the structure so that some windows are open more than others and in addition to that.
I don't know how much you could see but there are two white. Things inside. The trouble maybe can you get it out.
Maybe it's very sticky so very difficult to get it out. Maybe now you could see them better.
This is part of the cool
or off of a shrimp that lives inside the spines symbiotic away with spines so we learn a lot about natural symbiotic
life. Of how to make mechanical strong materials and optical fibers and it's all designed for these. Shrimp.
To be protected from environments so nobody can catch them and eat them. But for shrimp to be able to eat. Needs food.
So how would the shrimp get the food. The optical fibers provide enough elimination.
So that everything is attracted to light. Outcome of that there is always feast.
And so they have more than enough food. And the products of their life cycles are all there.
Excrements are used by sponge for it's own. Feeding So it's really interesting ideas. However.
What if and we're thinking about it. We don't know whether it would be. After all the outcome of the app but what if.
We'll look at that and we think about. A future building. So this building. This three D. Printed version.
Has every structural element that this point has this point is also building because shrimp lives inside.
But what if we would actually use the idea of energy.
Saving ideas the sponge has already evolved which is in this case to pump water.
Through the system
but in this case it could be a building where size of the openings of some of the windows would be open for airflow for
wind so that you could have most efficient energy balance of the building
but at the same time mechanical in it would have all these diagonal elements you can see again one mopin one closed so
that mechanical it's very strong
but it's actually on top of that is statically very pleasing what if it was building this is lesson from spawn.
But what if this building would also have lessons that we can take from that from butterflies
and this building will change color. Due to the weak with coming through certain places and during. Rain.
It would reveal certain messages and you would see a dynamic color change as natural conditions. Change or the windows.
Yet another project that will like it would have this ability to control.
The light intensity so we're really thinking about and it's not anywhere close here but we're thinking about building.
That's why I probably coughing us so far away that is it difficult to imagine that we're anywhere close.
But what if our future would be materials that combine smarts solutions from completely different organisms.
And that gives us an environment.
Materials an entire architecture that is capable of the most efficient way control airflow to control resistance from
ice formation to control optical properties reconfigure change depending on which side.
It is depending on what part of the world this building is going to be built in so that's if I where to dream big.
This is what I hope we can.
Make this building out of us interesting puzzles and interesting ideas that nature has created in nature has evolved
and probably waiting for us to uncover when we discover this spot spines five. So it's so there is.
I was very interested in Spawn Jews. A long time ago when I was a student in the Weizmann Institute.
So how do so should should I know where do you want me to hold it.
You know just so then you can go because you want to go and buy from now. OK for the last five or noticeable.
So this pint. When it's alive.
It's coated with a thin layer of brownish cells but all these windows are actually open for pumping water through it.
But it's attached to ocean floor right here. What is called Whole fast. Apparatus. But it has multiple function.
So not only if holds it inside the floor. But at the. And of each of these fibers. So these are all tickle fibers.
There's a crown of optical fibers surrounding this point which is this crown. Is has the Waveland saw the light.
So she waited with the. Bonus and tear that lives in the ocean floor.
And the light produced by this book Tear this couple into these fibers and it's shines.
Really similar to these fiber optical lamps like a compass like.
Light coming from from bacterias coupled to these lenses
and the end of each of the of this Piven is a lens for efficient coupling of light
and it shines very similar to these optical fibers that we all know
and we think that the we invented fiber optics just sixty years ago or so
but in fact this is one of the all the state organisms that exist
and they knew how to make possible optical things like them so it's really the same principle is the structure of these
fibers would have a higher index score and lower index cladding and the signal goes through the center of the fiber
and shines at the end it actually shines in many places because it.
Surely shines almost like a Christmas tree because it has a major point where light coming off is on the tip that some
of these fibers. Have branches and these also are.
Highlighted due to the out coupling of light in these what they shouldn't. Doesn't. It's deep in in the oath.
And there is no sunlight there so the only light that is coming are from from the ocean floor now may be you could see.
I hope you could see it one second. There are two here is inside these pines these two why things. If you see them.
If you can focus on though you can try to wiggle them around. These are close of the shrimp that lives inside.
So one may say that compared to shrimp. That is freely swimming.
It is a disadvantage because they cannot swim and find food. But it's actually an advantage.
First and then teaches pretty much nothing can crunch the six remaining strong material.
So the mechanical protect that there's no anyone is really for this room. They may want to but they cannot. Crack.
Crashed the glass now food comes from the fact that this is as a fiber optic
and it's enough light in this area in the ocean.
So that anything living is always attracted to light
and the density of food that these shrimp can eat is pretty high and the.
In this way it is nice combination of symbiotic life between. Bonus and bacteria. Sponge. And shrimp.
That leaves inside and. None of them alone would be able to survive. Especially.
In the conditions where there's almost no white and the food is really depleted.
As you go deeper into bone the ocean The together. It produces a very interesting system.
So that's how we think about new materials new designs of combining things together
and thinking how different organisms can teach us something that current materials or current devices Daunte use yet.
Just because it's up to see how. That you know I wouldn't recommend.
Flashing this to your clothes because it would immediately attach sin in mazing it's another feature that has a
credible. Ability to better than Belk or to attach anything. So could you. You have three laps. Yes.
I have one lab in three different locations or. When you describe this we live or. So the difference really.
I would still probably prefer everything to be in one location so that people talk to each other even want although we
always have a lot of activities together. In some ways they're divided by topics maybe that many topics that.
Generally speaking I would say in my one lap the lab that is here. In the engineering building.
There's a lot of projects that are related to.
Dynamic materials to self assembly to making colorful materials responsive materials
and it has a lot of work with more than one big man's. Optical devices and so on. It's one lamp.
Thinking about the ways one can.
For example some other paper that was sewn on on the car over Joan of how to make materials assemble. In. Absolutely.
Interesting patterns so that is in one wound. And it's very generally described. I would say as self assembly and.
Dynamic response of materials a lot of synthesis is done and this lamp. My other lab is doing a lot of research.
And they've found in materials
but specifically non-biological materials so using ph a plant as a inspiration to make materials that repel ice
materials that can be used in heat exchangers. Program.
It's found in generally but it's a lot of studies of what is it. Why they perform like that.
What would be the from the mental science and physical and chemical principles to understand.
What you want you to talk to mice than where dust before has come from. And that's really fluidics and.
Materials characterization. Related to. Wetting phenomena. These surface.
Will these structures that were made be whacked by different media.
And the third law is somewhat related to second but it's more on.
Biological falling so and not necessarily falling it would be a wrong thing to say falling. I would say.
By now interfaces. So in some cases you want to repel things for example want to rebuild. You want to rebel.
Muscles environment goals from ships in the ocean.
But in other cases it could be to create materials on which we can harvest algae.
For energy production but it's again there's a lot of questions one can ask.
One you need to harvest them so they feel comfortable
but then you need to have ways to release them from the structures
and services that are used for their production so the third.
Is mostly related to growing cultures crowing algae in their words or solutions words or conditions and.
I do identifying the structure.
How they interact with the materials that will make them to really come up with recipes.
For different applications so one can say we have a general approach that we learn from the teacher plant.
It's but it's. It's called platform technology. So it's really.
There are parts of that that can be combined in different ways depending whether you want to do it on glass on a metal
and depending whether you. Want to rip out more in things we want to repel ice.
So one can use it as a system design with different components. Depending what you want to do and we do study a lot.
How different combinations of materials together. Give the best outcome for a specific target.
It's strange that you
or all of our scientists are there so that's what I was all MY GOD YOU'RE VERY sensitive as Michael as you know that
injuries and a cough. But it's a surreal environment. There are cars but it's so strange when you look for help.
Metal that we met on corrosion or you something's whistling you know I'm sensitive.
And I met on corrosion between acceptance four times over for a little while.
But you found this is this material that you can control and that would change what's so strange that it.
Now we're five years and not earlier. That's true but I think that will make a lot of interesting.
We as a science in general are not talking about my web only if we open our eyes
and think in the very nontraditional terms about what we can learn from nature we can suddenly realize there have been
many interesting solutions that we have no idea.
Exist and many of them in fact extremely A simple in particular the pitcher plant that is very simple
but it is counter-intuitive So if we talk about it then. When I'm trying to explain.
The system when I say is counter-intuitive because everything in it is against the rules that are commonly used in.
In the current acknowledges
and well established rules for example if we think about how to make a material that has as little friction as possible.
So the way we do it now would polish everything Polish so that the surface has as minimal number of defects because
every defect produces friction. So if we talk about pipes.
Everything is polished because otherwise it would create turbulence. When we transport oil or water.
If it anywhere else. It's if we think about the materials that need to get all the laws friction possible.
You need to get rid of roughness now. What.
Peter plant is doing is that it actually creates at the extreme really rough surface it is structured surface which.
By all the laws of physics is supposed to be extremely. That if you want to produce friction free material.
However it is high friction when it's dry. So that AMS or.
Insects are capable of moving around on the surface of this beach or planned on a dry day being happy
and having no idea what may happen when there is rain.
But what happens when there is rain is that this structured surface picks up.
Water because it's hydrophilic it likes water. And by picking up water.
It creates a layer over layer of a liquid that is trapped inside the structure it's on the outcome of that that you
have a structured material. Braff material. But it.
Roughness has an secondary role its role is to hold water and Ellie and.
What insects would experience is not there are surface.
You use rough surface to create ultra smooth surface because your final outcome is the surface of water
and liquids have no defects. So that's what I'm saying is counter-intuitive because we use roughness.
To get rid of roughness in a way. And also we use liquid as a material.
That is not that many places where liquid can be considered as a material. It could be used. Let's say in three D.
Printing or anywhere else. To make something out of it but the final outcome is a solid. So until the solids.
In this case. Liquid is part of it together with the saw it it makes a new concept.
Liquid alone doesn't do it solid alone doesn't do it.
But combining these together gives an interesting outcome
and that's why I'm saying is counter-intuitive because we use roughness to get rid of roughness
and we use liquids stored in a way inside structures surfaces that alter nicely inside.
To take advantage of liquids that otherwise cannot be shaped cannot favor the runaway.
But now they're inside your material and they lend the material with its properties.
So this is brittle star used to have five arms. I just removed one arm for analysis. So it changes color.
Not all brittle stars do that but this species does. And during the day it's black and the reason is black.
During the day is that it has lenses on his surface that.
Regulate the white intensity depending how much lived outside
and the Receptus on to under the lens can work only in certain range. So when it's too bright.
We cover the lens with a black Big meant and therefore the entire organism changes color to black and at might
when actually they're active species they're doing everything at night
when that's not enough light they withdraw the Pigman back into the into the structure opening the lenses to more
efficient collection of light.
So the color change here is due to the dynamic nature of bringing a liquid in in this case big meant
and then was drawing it back.
So the idea of bringing liquids in into materials is now very common theme in many of my projects
and some of them are completely unrelated but it's thinking about liquids in and own. Materials.
One question of why they were black about why I should think so. It's.
Not mimicry it's not mimicking environment and in fact this is what.
At the beginning biological literature was using this as and another example of mimicking the environment
and changing the color accordingly.
It's actually opposite of what you would expect
and that was a big mistake that was what attracted me to this topic is best.
It's not hiding there goes it's just being even better seen during the day
and even more so during the night the function here is to optimize light collection and fair for during the night.
You want to get rid of Bateman and during the day you want to screen your lenses from excessive light.
So it's not mimicking the color of environment it's optimizing its technology which is in this case than any glances.
That's exactly what your memory biologist is not. That's correct.
So biology is always look for common very comfortable terminology of the way I used to suddenly to tell the story
but no the entire color change has a completely different function and it's to optimize
and improve the performance of optical elements and it's optics.
It's not only skeleton overall thinking that skeleton can also be an optical.
Element is really really interesting idea. Think about. Buildings that are of course mechanic or strong.
But also have builtin optical structures so the same construction is actually it's own up to Cologne
and that collects live or to reflect slides. So it's pretty interesting so different for you.
Biology says that you know the group more than organisms. This is the cure for six other functions.
I'd say I look more for. If I may say high tech properties.
If it's I'm less interested or those extremely important to understand what up the specific cellular.
Mechanisms that are involved in making this specific biological structures or what is the.
Biological cellular biology or or proteins or. Paula secularize that are involved in these functions.
I'm more interested in technology and more interest rate interested in devices that became an outcome of the evolution.
That the form. Hi tech functions so I'm interested in mechanics.
I'm interested in optics and I'm interested but optics beyond eyes.
We know all about our eyes because we need to know about it but other interesting optical solutions
and I'm looking for my next structures in nature how nature makes magnetic materials that are different from us.
So it's really I would say technical characteristics of biological materials right.
When you're looking your future how where are we are we humans with our technology will break.
Technological possibility where are we going to. That's the question.
I'm not sure I can say where we're going I hope I can tell you what I feel would be very important
and what I think he'll really interesting and very rich area would be too great.
Knowledge is materials that have the ability to self assemble self assemble that uses environment as a trigger.
For behavioral changes not to overuse and every time. Everything is run by hinges might change him.
Switching on and off they may have and this is what organisms do
and I hope the future might be to create a range of interesting materials that know how to switch behavior from.
Letting some in on not from being. From accepting water to repel in water because in some cases when it's too dry.
You really want the water to come in you want the building to breeze but when it's extremely wet
and there's a rain every day.
You actually want to repel it so how can one create the same material that will change its own function in response to
what happens outside. I think this is the future. At least it's my take on the future of our program is called the my.
And your or there are barriers accessibility to knowledge are gone down by the Internet.
Were you born in the world of never heard from again. Or do you think about the grease somehow created corners here.
It's a difficult question and I watch my grandson.
He is almost six years old with even when he was two he was already trying to look on the cell phone
and he knew how to move things around then that you and he at certain moment he came. To our T.V.
and Was trying to open window on the T.V. and He was he was so surprised that it's not doing it.
So there are problems maybe with the fact that you're on the
when we need to learn anything you can have access to any information. Any moment. You want it.
How ever at the same time I still hope that there is something that these days is easier to do than before
and I hope that we will benefit from that and this is multidisciplinary team. In the way.
So I'm a physical chemist my training northern engineer. I'm not a biologist. I'm not a medical doctor.
So I am a physical chemist. However I do a lot of physics math architecture and biology and medicine research.
Why that is possible is that. I feel that none of these disciplines alone capable of addressing.
Tomorrow's questions adequately or have the tools to do it in the most efficient way.
So I feel that when I can combine in my group I try to bring mathematicians physicists chemists medical doctors
and designers together.
The goal for that is to think about the way these people would address science in unusual ways just to give you a very
simple demonstration of that if if one wants to describe. Why this butterfly has these beautiful colors.
Actually you pretty much need to know optics physics and optics alone will describe what is happening
but this it with this butterfly. However. All our technological changes.
All the improvements that we had were due to the fact that. OK Were understand optics.
But what if I now use my chemistry knowledge and I encrypt chemical information inside this structure. What if.
Now this. Optical devise would have different chemistries in different locations.
So without chemistry pretty much anything that we've done with this material would be absolutely impossible.
Suddenly chemistry gave a nice spread of of applications
and possibilities that optics physics alone couldn't do chemistry alone also couldn't do it so chemistry was physics
with optics gave an interesting outcome but then. Yet another area. Having fluid mechanics assist in micro.
Brought the ideas of how liquids.
That would infiltrate these structures can move around in interesting ways
and in this way to create interesting unusual changes in color and response to environment so. In my opinion.
It's very important for kids for a future still have very clear Depp's in some traditional disciplines.
I would if I were now to. Have very high school student.
Choosing what to do I would say begin with choosing one discipline that you will learn very deeply as your first degree.
Then special for those who are interested in science and will stay in science. I as a Ph D.
Work where I would them create teams of different backgrounds coming together
and learning something from another community that you alone would know otherwise so this bringing together expertise
is I think the future and. I hope that we will see more and more. Papers and knowledge is that a clear outcome of.
Multiple disciplines contributing to. To the overall design.